>> Greg: FOR THE SECOND TIME
IN A MONTH, THE MEDIA
EXPERIENCED A REVERSE CHRISTMAS.
EXPECTING A PONY AND GETTING
PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
HERE IS TAPE OF CNN EARLIER.
>> WHAT IS IT?
WHAT IS IT?
>> I DON'T WANT IT.
I DON'T WANT IT.
NO!
>> Greg: POUR MEDIA.
THEY BUILT A WHOLE IMAGINARY
INDUSTRY AROUND RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, DESPERATELY EXPECTING
SOMETHING HUGE THAT VALIDATED
THEIR TWO-YEAR EFFORTS AND
EMOTIONS, THEIR HEARTS, CAREERS,
POCKETBOOKS RESTED ON TRUMP
BEING A RUSSIAN SPY.
>> THE U.S. PRESIDENT POSSIBLY
WORKING FOR THE RUSSIANS.
POSSIBLY AN UNWITTING POND,
SOMETHING THE FBI WAS
INVESTIGATING.
WHY ARE THESE LEAKS HAPPENING?
WHERE ARE THEY HAPPENING NOW?
WHAT DOES ROBERT MUELLER KNOW?
>> Greg: IT WAS NOT TO BE, MY
LITTLE ROUND FELLA.
THE FANTASY OF TRUMP IS A
RYERSON -- AS A RUSSIAN AGENT
WAS JUST FANTASY.
THE MEDIA WOULD'VE PREFERRED THE
PRESIDENT HAD BEEN A RUSSIAN
STOOGE EVEN DESTROYED THE
COUNTRY.
HENCE THEIR REACTION.
>> BILL BARR HAS DECIDED HIS
LEGACY.
HE IS FINE WITH HIS LEGACY BEING
THE AG WHO TOOK ONE FOR THE
TEAM.
>> IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
POLITICAL COMMERCIAL FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> A BLACK MARK ON HIS
PREVIOUSLY ILLUSTRIOUS CAREER.
>> IS THIS SOMETHING WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO SEE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES, NOT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE ENTIRE
CNN STAFF.
WHEN YOUR REALITIES OF FAILURE,
THEN THE FAIRY TALE BECOMES
REALITY SO IT'S ANALOGY TIME.
REMEMBER IN HIGH SCHOOL YOU HAD
A FRIEND WHO GOT DUMPED AND IT
WAS THE WORST THING EVER.
HE WOULDN'T CHANGE HIS SOCKS FOR
THE REST OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
HE COULD LET GO.
BUT YOU, FRIEND, KNEW THAT YOU
HAD TO GET HIM TO MOVE ON SO YOU
TOLD HIM DUDE, MOVE ON.
LIVE YOUR OWN LIFE.
MEDIA, AND YOUR PAL.
IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON.
YET, YOU GOT DUMPED AND IT HURTS
BUT CLEANING LIKE THIS MAKES YOU
LOOK WEAK AND STUPID.
IT PREVENTS GROWTH,
RELATIONSHIPS, NEW OBSESSIONS
AND LOVES AND THERE ARE OTHER
STORIES OUT THERE.
WHAT'S GREAT ABOUT TRUMP, A NEW
STORY IS LIKE A BUS.
YOU MISS ONE, THEY'LL BE ANOTHER
IN 10 MINUTES.
CHEER UP, PRESS.
GO TO THE GYM.
DITCHED DOUGHNUTS.
MAKE YOURSELF PRESENTABLE.
RIGHT NOW NO ONE WANTS TO BE
WITH YOU, NOT LIKE THIS.
YOU ARE PITIFUL, PATHETIC.
DANA, WATCHING THEIR REACTION
TELLS YOU WHAT WITH THE OUTCOME
HAVE BEEN IF IT WERE THE
OPPOSITE?
HOW WOULD THEY HAVE REACTED?
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THAT.
ALSO FOR US.
WHAT WOULD IT HAVE BEEN LIKE TO
BE LIKE WHOA.
>> Greg: DANA, WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN FAIR AND BALANCED.
>> Jesse: I WOULD'VE FIGURED
OUT A WAY TO SPIN IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WE WOULDN'T HAVE 14
PEOPLE WHO AGREE WITH EACH OTHER
AROUND A TABLE.
>> Dana: I THINK ON THE MEDIA,
THERE IS SOMETHING INTERESTING,
SOME STORY TURNED OUT TO BE
TRUE.
FOR ALL THE STORIES WHERE THEY
SAID PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WANTING
TO FIRE MUELLER THIS WEEKEND.
IT TURNS OUT YEAH.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT BOSSES
ALWAYS DO.
I WANT TO FIRE SOMEBODY EVERY
DAY.
>> Dana: THE PERSISTENT RUMOR
THAT CAME UP ALL THE TIME THAT
DON JR. EXPECTED TO BE INDICTED.
DON JR. TELLING FRIENDS HE
EXPECT TO BE INDICTED.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THAT COULD
POSSIBLY BE TRUE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
I AM SO EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT
OTHER ISSUES.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO STAY ON
THIS ALL WEEK.
>> Greg: JESSE, I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE AN ANALOGY ON DECK.
>> Jesse: I DO, REMEMBER THE
MOVIE "THE FUGITIVE."
FALSELY ACCUSED, IMPRISONED,
ESCAPED.
HE FOUND THE REAL KILLER.
IN THIS CASE, IT'S HILLARY AND
OBAMA.
>> Greg: TERRIBLE ANALOGY.
>> Dana: I LIKE THAT ONE.
>> Greg: HE COMPARED IT TO A
MOVIE PLOT.
IT'S NOT AN ANALOGY.
>> Jesse: THE ANALOGY POLICE
ARE KIND OF HARSH OVER HERE.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
MUELLER WAS THE HERO, THE HERO
DID NOT DELIVER.
NOW NADLER BECOMES THE HERO BUT
NADLER ISN'T SMART ENOUGH,
TELEGENIC ENOUGH, TRUSTWORTHY
ENOUGH, MODERATE ENOUGH, SMART
ENOUGH, ANYTHING, TO TAKE THE
TORCH FROM MUELLER AND CARRY IT
ACROSS THE END ZONE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANYBODY BEHIND
HIM SAYING YOU ARE THE NEW WHITE
KNIGHT.
AT THIS POINT, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
OBSTRUCTION CASE IS TOO THIN FOR
THE MEDIA TO SELL IN A WAY, THE
AUDIENCE ISN'T GOING TO
LOVE IT THE WAY THEY LOVE
COLLUSION BECAUSE IT'S TOO
CONFUSING AND THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE ON
TO SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Greg: MARIE, CAN THEY MOVE
ON?
>> Marie: I THINK THE MUELLER
REPORT DID DELIVER.
I'M NOT UNDERWHELMED BY IT.
>> Jesse: IT DELIVERED FOR
TRUMP.
>> Marie: NO, JESSE.
>> Jesse: NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION.
>> Marie: THAT'S NOT WHAT IT
SAID.
YOU SAYING IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE.
>> Jesse: NO ONE CHARGED WITH
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION.
>> Marie: I WANT US TO READ
THIS AND WE CAN BE DISTURBED BY
THINGS AND WHAT RUSSIA DID
INDEPENDENT OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THINGS TRUMP HAS
DONE.
WE CAN ADMIT THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO TO OUR
POLITICAL CORNERS.
WE CAN READ IT AND SAY IF I WAS
ON A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, I
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT THAT WAY.
I WOULDN'T HAVE TRIED TO ACCEPT
HELP FROM THE RUSSIANS.
IT'S OKAY FOR TRUMP SUPPORTERS
TO ADMIT.
I'M GIVING YOU PERMISSION.
>> Greg: WHY, THANK YOU.
>> Dan: HERE'S A NEW POLICY,
THE NEGATIVE INFORMATION
FALLACY.
YOU ARE CONFLATING NEGATIVE
INFORMATION.
YES, THE REPORT IS NOT ALL
FLATTERY ALL THE TIME.
PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES AND THEY
ARE HUMAN.
BECAUSE IT'S NEGATIVE
INFORMATION, IT DOES NOT MEAN
THE TRUMP TEAM COMMITTED A
CRIME.
NO ONE WAS CHARGED WITH THOSE
CRIMES AND I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU
CAN'T GET PAST IT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF AN
ESTABLISHED CONNECTION IN THIS
COLLUSION THING.
IT'S A FRAUD.
CAN YOU JUST TAKE THE LOSS ON
THIS AND SAY I MADE A BIG
MISTAKE?
I'M SORRY TO AMERICA.
I SHOULD NOT HAVE --
>> Dana: SHE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
DO THIS BASED ON THIS REPORT.
I THINK YOU CAN READ IT AND GO
WOW.
I THINK DEMOCRATS SHOULD SAY WE
ACCEPT THAT THERE IS NO
COLLUSION.
THEY SAID THE PRESIDENT WAS A
TRAITOR.
I THINK THAT ONE SHOULD BE -- I
THINK YOU CAN READ IT AS A
DEMOCRAT AND READ THE
OBSTRUCTION PIECING GO GOSH,
THIS IS REALLY TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: I READ IT AS AN
AMERICAN I'M HAPPY THAT OUR
PRESIDENT IS NOT A SPY.
>> Dana: ON MARCH 24.
>> Jesse: HE BEAT THE PANTS
OFF HILLARY.
>> Dan: THERE WAS NEVER
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, EVER.